[Musique]
salut c'est monsieur grue aujourd'hui je
m'adresse à tous ceux qui vivent en
france qui d'ailleurs a très très loin
avec l'arrivée d'un nouveau fabricant de
smartphones dans l'hexagone très très
prochainement ce fabricant c'est au pot
vous allez voir c'est vraiment une bonne
nouvelle et on en parle
après shiomi qui arrivait ya pas très
longtemps qui a ouvert son mister à
paris voici copeaux arrive en france
alors au pot ne devrait pas arriver avec
une boutique en france mais ils vont
vendre leurs produits directement dans
l'hexagone et plus largement en europe
tous ceux qui voulaient acheter des
smartphones chinois devait les importer
les constructeurs chinois arrivent en
france arrive en force en france j'irais
même parce que le marché français est
mûr est prêt à accepter tous ces
produits chinois c'est super intéressant
pour nous du fait que des marques comme
shiomi et comme au pot arrive
directement france c'est que
mécaniquement çà peut faire baisser les
prix
d'autres smartphones haut de gamme
milieu de gamme apporte en tout cas une
concurrence un peu plus forte et un
éventail de choix beaucoup plus large
aux consommateurs avant toute chose à
vendre en dire plus je vous poser une
question est ce que vous connaissez au
pot si oui qu'est ce que vous savez de
pau et si vous en connaissez beaucoup
quel produit vous plait plus s'y
opposent vous marquez tout ça en
commentaire vous avez trois gourdes 1
le csii deux trois bons pour s'y mettre
une pause le marquer revenir en mai
lecture et on est partis opposés l'un
des fabricants leaders au point de vue
international qui se situe entre la 4e
place mondiale et la cinquième place
mondiale
c'est le numéro deux en chine après
huawei sont très connus pour les
produits milieu de gamme et d'entrée de
gamme mais également sur le haut de
gamme est là justement ils vont revenir
en force avec un produit qui s'appelle
le find x est pas le fine 10 pouces une
boîte qui a été créée en 2001 et qui est
aussi très connu pour voir des produits
innovants par exemple d'en fabriquer un
smartphone avec une caméra rotative que
vous pouvez passer en caméra principale
ou en sel filles c'est une marque qui a
dans son adn l'innovation et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant au pot fait partie
du même groupe que one piece d'ailleurs
regardez ce que j'ai là d'ici quelques
jours on va parler du one + 6 qui est
présent donc abonnez vous restez
connectés et puisqu'on est dans les
cartons
regardez aussi changer le son nouveau
micro ça changera de cette espèce de
micro filaire là aujourd'hui avec plus
intéressant nombre on s'en reparlera une
prochaine fois on a une date et un lieu
le 19 juin prochain au soir ou au louvre
à paris au pot va présenter son nouveau
smartphone haut de gamme le fine x et va
présenter sa stratégie d'implantation en
france et en europe
ils vont dit
quels seront les produits qui vont être
disponibles au catalogue un petit peu
toutes les informations sur
l'implantation de la marque sa top
d'ailleurs on pose si vous regardez
cette vidéo je suis très intéressé pour
venir pour couvrir l'événement pour
relater un peu ce qui va se passer par
les du phénix et paraître votre
implantation en france dont vous pouvez
inviter je serais très heureux d'être là
find x pourquoi x je vous ai dit c'est x
et pas 10 alors pour apple on disait
l'iphone os x c'est l'iphone 10 on parle
du samsung galaxy mix est pas le dise
lampard est bien dufaye x et non pas du
fayoum pourquoi x ça renvoie à la quête
de la marque d'innovation davanture
d'extrême on voit la volonté de la
marque on va leur adn d'aller chercher
des produits toujours innovant de
prendre des risques
qu'est ce que ces failles x pourrait
avoir dans le ventre il faut avoir des
caractéristiques techniques assez proche
du wan +62 xiaomi 1008 de l'iphone
disent en gros de ce qui se fait de
mieux au niveau de la téléphonie mobile
aujourd'hui on devrait avoir toutes les
nouvelles techno un équivalent de faith
a dit une recherche très rapide qui
pourrait vous rechargez votre smartphone
à 100% en à peu près 15 minutes et
quelques infos qui ont chuté bien
évidemment j'ai pris bonne note de ce
qui a fuité on pourrait avoir un écran
amoled de 6 points 4 pouces avec une
résolution de 2340 par 1080 pixels 16
millions de couleurs
une batterie de 3600 45 millions terreur
sera disponible en deux couleurs en noir
et en blanc
on pourra avoir un processeur 8 coeurs
cadencé à 2,8 ghz 8 gigas de ram 128
giga de stockage les tourne sous android
aurait eu 8 points 1
yorick trois caméras deux à l'arrière 16
et 20 mégapixels une à l'avant en 25
méga pixels on pourrait filmer en 4k et
toussa toussa toussa
voilà pour ce différend un faux lent moi
ce que je vous conseille de faire c'est
de vous abonner parce qu'on en parle et
très très prochainement de ses fans x6
au pot vous ne regardez je suis bien
évidemment votre rôle pour venir couvrir
l'événement et si c'est pas le cas on en
parlera quand même
en attendant je vous invite à laisser
des jolies pousse à rester connectés a
marqué tous aux questions suggestions
tout ce que vous voulez directement en
bas en commentaire soyez sage je vous
embrasse n'oubliez pas en rester dans le
coin parce que on va parler du one + 6
très très très très prochainement j'ai
vraiment hâte de le tester vous de
regarder ce qu'ils vont mais pas mal de
choses qui vont arriver aussi
aussi le test de cette monde qualité
varié pas mal de choses donc restez
connectés d'ici là soyez ça je vous
embrasse
à bientôt avec les meilleurs
[Musique]